it was here in the albanian village of
maha mother
the earthquake was felt the strongest
gsella says he had little time to do
anything but run I just grabbed my
children everything collapsed within
seconds I ran out screaming earthquake
earthquake 34 kilometres away in the
city of Duras the force of the
earthquake damaged the walls of this
high-rise building jamming the door and
trapping people inside the girl was
under a chair but the quake was so
strong that it shook both her and the
chair one brick fell off the wall and
almost hit her there's little lift of
many of Doras as hotels a huge setback
for businesses and a city that relies
heavily on tourism hundreds of houses -
and now just rubble many have nowhere to
live
Rudy's trying to help them through this
app we can see if the building has been
totally destroyed or it can be repaired
and then we can see when the family
where the family lives so I say here
that if they live in a tent there in the
relatives or even they do live in their
building again but the community has
come together providing food and clothes
to those in need
today we're going to have beans and rice
and it will be will make at least the
let's say 250 300 portions and it's
happening with little help from the
Albanian government so volunteers have
stepped in a versa for me we are alone
in this business there is an
administrative office but it's been
closed for more than 10 days people come
here talk to us about their problems and
daily challenges after the earthquake
there's no one else to help them back in
Marja mother this makeshift shelter is
where Zeller and his family are now
living they'll spend a cold winter here
waiting for help they fear may not come
Laura Frick Berg al Jazeera